et vous avez entendu tout à l'heure un
sergueï lavrov s'exprimer à l'issue de
la conférence internationale sur la
libye outreau le chaos libyen beaucoup
de sujets évoqués notre journaliste
katia avec nick a posé une question au
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
écoutez
monsieur lavrov la france a récemment
exprimé le besoin de créer une force sur
le front de l'information thierry
burckhart le chef d'état major des
armées a lui même déclaré que la lutte
informationnel participer de la lutte
d'influencé
la pologne a évoqué la situation à la
frontière biélorusse comme un exemple
d'une telle guerre de l'information que
pensez vous de ces déclarations et sur
les sujets de l'information qui est il
et des discussions entre vos homologues
français sur les problèmes que
rencontrent rt en france
japonais moi
je comprends pourquoi vous me posez
cette question vous n'êtes probablement
pas en mesure de la poser aux dirigeants
français car vous n'êtes pas accrédité à
l'elysée n'est ce pas aujourd'hui nous
avons attiré l'attention de nos
interlocuteurs là dessus nous avons
attiré leur attention sur le fait que
cela ainsi que de nombreuses autres
actions de nos collègues occidentaux y
compris français contredisent
directement les engagements qui ont été
pris au début des années 90 à
l'initiative de l'occident au sein de
l'eau à eux et qui exige la suppression
de tout obstacle à l'accès à toute
source d'information tant à l'intérieur
des pays concernés qu'à l'étranger
nous en avons parlé et bien entendu nous
en parlons souvent en principe nous
pensons que la rhétorique que l'on
entend y compris l' annonce de plan de
militarisation de l'espace ou la
proclamation de concept de guerre de
l'information est une chose très
dangereuse vous voyez ces mots vont
ensuite se transformer en projets
concrets
certains gagneront de l'argent avec ça
d'autres se feront un nom un politique
mais en fin de compte de plus en plus de
menaces seront créés
j'ai entendu que le président macron
avait signé un décret quel qu'en soit le
nom de ce document un décret prévoyant
la création d'une agence de lutte contre
la désinformation en provenance de
l'étranger j'ai demandé aujourd'hui à
nos interlocuteurs le ministre des
affaires étrangères et la ministre des
armées de nous expliquer comment
fonctionnera cette agence en réponse
nous serons bien entendu prêt à
expliquer comment fonctionne les
structures étatiques concernées dans
notre pays mais ce problème existe et il
devient de plus en plus graves